we were told by the previous president
that we were absent the uk was
absolutely at the front of the queue
or the line when it came to a trade deal
we are obviously not the difference
being that we you now have a new
president what's the problem
well i think the focus right now is uh
is on the the trade that we do have 220
billion dollars a year in goods and
services not to mention the one and a
half trillion dollars in
in
investment both ways that creates
millions of jobs on both sides of the
atlantic that's the focus while the
president focuses on the u.s domestic
economy after covet of course emerging
the president prime minister
discussed the build back better world
initiative that the g7
uh have undertaken how important that is
to all of us we're talking about the
first and fifth largest economies in the
world and we're doing a tremendous
amount i don't think we should focus on
so-called trade agreements as uh as the
be all the end-all we're working toward
a number of of new opportunities you saw
the prime minister uh discuss and the
president uh lamb for instance as as one
small step i believe they're working on
new rules for import of ruminants that
is
sheep and land
into the united states that's one small
step but again 220 billion dollars a
year in in two-way trade is a very
important thing and we'll look to grow
that but we need stability certainly at
home with our economy and we need to
focus on the climate situation as well
we'll come to that um u.s uk trade deal
not important then is that what you're
saying
now i think trade is vitally important
and the president and the prime minister
uh
agreed and discussed that we'll keep
working on trade we've got a lot to do
at home and i think it's important for
everyone that the u.s uh economy is uh
emerging from covid well we're all
keeping a close eye on this these are
things we have to work on together and
the g7 which britain of course has
chaired this year
is an important part of that
so if it is important how likely is a
trade deal in the near future
look i think we just have to take things
one step at a time uh keep focusing on
the trade that we have
emerging from covid uh and more and more
as we indicated uh focusing on the
importance of a green economy the prime
minister uh underscored that in his u.n
speech and the president certainly
underscored the importance of
of green
of uh putting more money into climate
and we're looking forward to the cop 26
conference that will take place uh here
in glasgow in just a few weeks time and
we will come to that but in the meantime
joe biden is the most irish president um
i think it's fair to say since jfk is
his view
on the northern ireland protocol part of
the reason that is a sticking point for
a u.s uk trade deal
the president has made very clear that
the importance to to him and to so many
americans and frankly uh to so many in
the uk and uh that includes northern
ireland uh is the good friday accords
which uh we had a strong uh role in
we're proud of that role it brought
peace and and stability uh after years
and years of tragic violence uh
preserving the good friday accords is
what the president has said
must be kept in mind i think there's
broad agreement on that
and we want to see the the parties in
terms of the northern ireland protocol
uh
work towards that through diplomacy
through conversations and discussion
i think there's ways forward i think
everyone agrees that
and it can be done they just need to uh
to focus on that uh but keeping the good
friday accords in mind and that's
president biden's point
um if you'll indulge me mr ambassador we
did have a secretary of state on the
program i'm sure you heard earlier on in
the week and he said the problem is that
your president just doesn't understand
the northern ireland protocol this is
what he had to say you could bear with
us and have a quick listen
we think he's wrong because the truth is
that unless we have a sustainable
solution that enables trade to continue
between gb
and northern ireland then we are going
to have uh issues and that itself would
become a challenge to the belfast
agreement so those who believe
as we do in the the hard-won peace and
stability in northern ireland have to
make the northern ireland protocol work
on a sustainable basis
now i apologize that he wasn't
particularly diplomatic but you get his
point
look i think again everyone would agree
that the
good friday accords the belfast
agreement
that brought and have preserved
peace in northern ireland for decades
now
are vitally important that's the
president's point
there are ways forward to find a way
through the northern ireland protocol
which is of course separate from the
good friday accords
that can make sure that the importance
of those accords are preserved uh and
that's the job for for the uk sorry mr
ambassador and my question was does does
the does the president understand the
northern ireland protocol or not
i think he certainly does and he's made
his point very clear that it's important
to keep the good friday accords very
much at the forefront and preserve that
i want to talk to you about [ __ ] 26 in
just a second but before that let's talk
about afghanistan
if we may um
there was quite a lot of criticism from
our defense secretary about the way the
united states unilaterally decided to
pull out of afghanistan how damaging was
that
well i don't think unilateral is the
right word to use i was with secretary
blinken when we went to nato in march at
the ministerial and discussed the way
forward in afghanistan as you know
president trump had signed
an agreement
that we would be withdrawing from
afghanistan we discussed and consulted
with our allies who with whom we went in
together in afghanistan 20 years ago
and in april we came to the decision
after much discussion uh different
viewpoints were expressed but we came to
a unified decision that we would be
withdrawing
and so we were working in that direction
may june and july
what changed was the situation uh in
terms of the afghans themselves the
security forces the government on the
ground
in august and we had to adapt to that as
the prime minister and president
discussed in the oval office it was
remarkable what we did together then
to evacuate an enormous number of people
in a very short amount of time within
the parameters that we had and we'll
continue to uh to engage in terms of
diplomacy development in afghanistan but
we'll also focus on the much broader
challenges we have in the world
so what happened then was it the fact
that u.s intelligence was lacking in
afghanistan
look intelligence can tell you what the
capabilities of afghanistan
defense forces security forces were
they can't necessarily know
or predict exactly what individual
leaders will do
uh the situation on the ground changed
there and as we've always done we then
had to change together our military
forces did a remarkable job uh in
developing a new plan and the airlift
that was carried out was uh was frankly
very historic
what's the us view on the taliban now is
speaking to the head of the armed
services here in the united kingdom and
he said they're a grump they're a group
of country boys and they've changed and
we should give them a break
you know the secretary has said and
certainly i agree uh that we need to see
what the taliban do not just what they
say
uh and so we of course have been uh
talking to them we had been through
through doha for uh for many months
um and laid very clear what our
expectations are and and what they can
expect from us uh if if they meet those
expectations and the commitments that
they've undertaken
and we'll continue to do that so it is
an evolving story and we are working
very closely with allies friends and
partners particularly the uk
in terms of the diplomacy there and
watching the situation quite closely
yeah but we are seeing um girls being
told that they can't go to school
anymore uh we're seeing journalists
being tied up behind cars and dragged
through the streets of kabul we're
seeing people who used to work with the
allied forces now being rounded up and
shot in front of their loved ones what
more do we need
well i think you have seen some some
really disturbing
and uh
discouraging scenes from the taliban
that's the taliban and what they're
doing and what we need to do is stand by
our values and make clear that if they
expect
any kinds of
support recognition
their way forward in the international
community
that they're going to have to meet the
commitments they have
so this is what we do in the world of
diplomacy
and we'll keep watching that and uh
again it's something we do as as
partners uh a lot of consultation uh in
the region on the ground
uh i think we both have diplomatic
representation in doha and we'll
certainly discuss the way forward and
see how things develop and evolve there
even as we deal with so many other
challenges around the world
hindsight's a wonderful thing isn't it
um would it have been done differently
the withdrawal from afghanistan if we'd
known then what we know now
again i can't predict from from
hindsight i think we
this administration came in
looked at the situation on the ground
the president's been very clear we went
in together
uh after 9 11 for a particular purpose
20 years ago and trillions of dollars
later
the president made it determined that
determination
that it was time
for us to to pull out in terms of our
military
and focus on some of the other
challenges we need to take those
resources
and focus them on on other things having
accomplished
what we initially set out to do and that
is eliminate osama bin laden and the
threats that perpetrated
9 11 20 years ago
so even now it's considered that it was
the right decision
that's right the president stands by
that decision and uh what we're focused
on is uh the whole array of challenges
that we face to our broader uh security
and stability interests those of our our
partners and allies as well
and first and foremost that includes the
climate challenge where we need to focus
resources uh and the uk uh is taking a
strong lead in that as the head of the
cup 26 process
you keep taking me back there mr
ambassador so okay let's go with that
one what does cop 26 need in order to be
a success
well i think we've seen some some
progress the president announced of
course at the u.n on tuesday morning
before he saw the prime minister later
that day than in washington
a doubling of the u.s financial
commitment that's a doubling on what was
already a doubling in april
so in fact it's the double-double
in terms of our financial commitment
because the president has underscored
how vital this is we are at an
inflection point a historic inflection
point and i think uh you know looking
back uh over the decades what we've done
together to face the great challenges of
any age
is put our minds to it put our resources
to it and we can deal with this this
climate challenge uh it's going to be a
tremendous opportunity in glasgow to
bring leaders together not just
the us and the uk of course
but
more than a hundred countries uh coming
together to discuss all aspects of this
it's really got to be a full-on
effort to deal with climate change to
to to meet the goals that are set that
can help us stave off the catastrophic
uh consequences if we don't deal with
this challenge
how damaging will it be if the chinese
don't attend
well i think we'll have to see we've
seen some uh words from the chinese
again at the u.n this week uh
and
their participation of course is
important they're the second largest
economy in the world the united states
being the first britain being the fifth
it's these large economies that do have
to take a lead
but it involves everybody being involved
and i think the chinese will see
that they have interests here as well
the climate affects them too
and their future and the future of their
people as well as their economic growth
is it easy being green
i thought the prime minister's remark
was was very spot on
we need to be green and there are ways
of doing it the technology
and innovation is really quite
remarkable i often say you know if i
could go back 30 years
i think i might go a different direction
than diplomacy and focus on on some of
the things they're doing in terms of
green energy green technology
innovation that's where the smart money
is going and just as we did with the
moonshot or
frankly back in world war ii
when we banded together and accomplished
what many people thought we never could
do
to defeat the challenge of that time i
think we can
deal with this time so
kermit the frog
certainly is in all our minds these days
just before i let you go mr ambassador
as you said you are here to serve for as
long as the president would like you to
obviously you're incredibly diplomatic
um perhaps uh he might want you to go to
paris next to sort out president macron
because he's not very happy with you
guys at the moment
paris is a lovely city uh and certainly
not far from here
uh i'll stick to london uh for now this
is where the secretary has asked me to
be you have a great team here a great
relationship with
with the united kingdom united states
united kingdom united in dealing with
all of these um challenges that we have
and i go into this uh this weekend and
this autumn uh
very optimistic uh that we can
accomplish a lot together